Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de parler du sujet « Pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
comprenez pas
quand les Français parlent ?».
Plus généralement, pourquoi on ne comprend pas quand les natifs
d'une langue parlent ?
J'avais envie de parler de ce sujet parce
que c'est quelque chose, c'est un problème que je rencontre dans mon
apprentissage
du Japonais.
Je voulais donc partager mon expérience, mais aussi mon point de vue et les
solutions
possibles je pense.
Avant de commencer, vous avez le script de la vidéo disponible gratuitement
sur mon
Patreon.
Vous pouvez également me soutenir pour 4 euros par mois et je remercie les
6 personnes
qui me soutiennent.
Et je crois que c'est tout !
Oui, bon, on va dire que c'est tout.
Du coup, pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne comprend pas quand les natifs parlent ?
J'ai fait une vidéo sur la courbe « Dunning Kruger ».
Donc, « Dunning Kruger », c'est
la courbe qui dit que quand on commence quelque chose, on a l'impression
d'apprendre
très rapidement.
Souvent, on appelle ça « la montagne de la stupilité », « stupidity
pick ».
Je ne me rappelle plus, mais en gros, c'est qu'au début, on a l'impression
d'apprendre très rapidement et on a l'impression de pouvoir ... que ça va être
facile en fait,
qu'apprendre le français par exemple, ça va être facile.
Quand j'ai appris le japonais, je me rappelle que je voyais des vidéos qui
disaient si
vous connaissez 1000 mots de vocabulaire, vous connaissez déjà 80% des mots
les plus
utilisés.
Quand on voit ça, on se dit « Si je connais 80% des mots qui sont utilisés,
juste en
apprenant 1000 mots, je vais pouvoir comprendre facilement et je vais
pouvoir parler."
J'étais en haut de cette montagne et du coup après, sur la courbe de
Dunning Kruger,
il y a la vallée du désespoir, donc, The Despair Valley, où on se rend
compte qu'on réalise
qu'en fait, ça va être beaucoup plus difficile.
Et ça, je pense que c'est le cas avec quand il faut comprendre des natifs
ou quand il
faut parler avec des natifs.
C'est la même chose, par exemple, peut-être quand vous regardez ce genre de
vlog dans
un français lent.
Là, je parle un peu plus lentement que d'habitude et j'essaye d'utiliser un
français
assez simple.
Et peut-être qu'après, quand vous essayez de regarder du contenu natif,
vous avez cette
impression que le gap entre les deux est impossible à franchir, que vous
avez beaucoup
du mal à passer au contenu natif.
Ça, plus le plateau intermédiaire.
Donc, le plateau intermédiaire, c'est quand on connaît les règles de
grammaire basique,
qu'on a un niveau moyen, mais qu'on a l'impression de stagner tout
simplement parce qu'on a
un niveau scolaire, on va dire, moyen, mais qu'on a du mal à passer à
l'étape supérieure
d'un contenu natif, par exemple.
Comment faire pour passer d'un contenu, d'un podcast en slow French à un
contenu natif
parce que c'est ça l'objectif.
Récemment, j'ai commencé à regarder du contenu natif en japonais et j'aime
beaucoup.
Je prends énormément de plaisir à faire de l'immersion, je m'amuse beaucoup
et je
sens que mon apprentissage réaccélère.
Mais avant ça, plusieurs fois dans mon apprentissage, j'apprenais le
japonais, je regardais des
podcasts de slow Japanese.
Plusieurs fois, j'ai essayé de regarder du contenu natif et je ne
comprenais rien.
Et du coup, c'était un peu désespérant parce que je me disais je travaille,
je travaille,
mais à la fin, je ne comprends rien quand c'est les japonais qui parlent.
Ce qui est un peu bête parce que quand vous apprenez une langue, vous
voulez parler naturellement
avec des personnes du pays.
Et peut-être que ça vous fait la même chose, c'est-à-dire que vous regardez
ce
genre de podcast, vous vous dites ça va, j'arrive à comprendre, je suis à
l'aise,
etc.
Et que dès que vous passez sur du contenu natif, là, vous êtes complètement
perdu.
La raison à ça, c'est qu'il y a plusieurs nuances d'une langue.
Je pense que sur la miniature, je vais écrire « 50 shades of French ».
Et ça, c'est pareil pour n'importe quelle langue, c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
maîtriser
les bases, on peut connaître les règles, les règles basiques.
On peut avoir un bon français mais un français neutre, on va dire.
Après, en fait, il y a plein de nuances à avoir.
Et c'est là où il y a une grosse différence entre connaître du français
simple et connaître
toutes les nuances du français.
Connaître le français simple, enfin le français basique, c'est pouvoir
utiliser le passé
composé, pouvoir utiliser l'imparfait, pouvoir parler au futur, futur
proche, ce genre de
choses, du conditionnel, etc.
Et ça, c'est en fait les règles basiques de français, c'est-à-dire que si
je vous
demande qu'est-ce que vous avez fait le week-end dernier, vous allez devoir
utiliser du passé
composé.
Si je vous demande comment était votre enfance, vous allez utiliser de
l'imparfait, vous
allez plus ou moins mélanger les deux temps.
Si je vous dis qu'est-ce que vous allez faire le week-end prochain, vous
allez me dire
« Ah, je vais faire ça, je vais faire ci », vous allez utiliser du futur
proche.
Et du coup, quand vous commencez à maîtriser ça, en fait, vous pouvez avoir
l'impression
de connaître le français.
Vous commencez à être à l'aise pour comprendre du français basique et
pouvoir parler de
manière basique en français.
Et quand on est à cette étape-là, je pense que c'est là où on arrive un peu
au plateau
intermédiaire et aussi à la vallée qu'on commence à remonter la vallée du
désespoir
sur la courbe de Dunning-Kröger.
Je pense qu'à ce moment-là, il y a deux choses, il y a déjà le vocabulaire,
le
nombre de mots que vous connaissez.
1000 mots ce n'est pas suffisant pour connaître une langue.
Je pense que cette idée de connaître 1000 mots pour connaître 80% des mots
utilisés
par les natifs, c'est un peu une fausse bonne idée.
C'est une bonne idée parce que bien évidemment, on veut apprendre les mots
les plus fréquents
en premier.
On ne voulait pas apprendre des mots qui ne sont jamais utilisés.
Donc, se concentrer sur ces 1000 mots, c'est une bonne idée pour acquérir,
pour apprendre
le bon vocabulaire en premier.
Mais après, si vous vous dites que je vais apprendre 1000 mots, je vais
être capable
de parler et de comprendre, là, c'est une erreur.
Tout simplement parce qu'après, il y a énormément de vocabulaire et même si
on
n'utilise pas beaucoup de vocabulaire, on connaît beaucoup plus de
vocabulaire qu'on
utilise.
Il y a une connaissance passive, une connaissance active.
Un natif de manière active, il va utiliser environ 10 000 mots de
vocabulaire, mais de
manière passive, il va connaître, il va pouvoir comprendre 20, 30 000 mots,
40 000 mots,
ça dépend.
Et du coup, ça, c'est important parce que dans beaucoup de cas, on
comprend, c'est-à-dire
qu'en tant que français, je peux comprendre quand je lis un texte, mais ça
se trouve,
je n'utilise pas beaucoup de ces mots.
Et ensuite, il y a cette partie vocabulaire et ensuite, il y a la partie
plus structure
des phrases et, je dirais, intuition.
Parce qu'en fait, il y a une grosse différence entre l'apprentissage
théorique et la pratique.
Ça, je m'en suis rendu compte dans mon apprentissage du japonais.
Quand vous apprenez le japonais, quand vous apprenez à construire une
phrase ou vous
construisez une phrase complète, par exemple, pour dire qu'est-ce que c'est
?
Qu'est-ce
que c'est ?
On va dire « Ah, Kore ha nan desu ka ».
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Et du coup, ça,
c'est vraiment « Kore ha nan desu ka ».
C'est vraiment la phrase typique, vraiment la théorie
pure et dure.
C'est-à-dire que, quand vous ouvrez un livre, ils vont vous dire « Oui,
voilà, Kore ceci
nandesuka ».
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Enfin, oui, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Quand j'ai commencé à regarder du contenu natif, je me rappelle, je prends
cet exemple
parce que ça m'avait marqué, mais je me rappelle avoir regardé une vidéo.
Et là, il y a un japonais qui dit « Nani kore, nani kore ».
Et en fait, j'ai compris
que il disait « Kore ha nan desu ka ».
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Et en fait, il le disait un peu
d'une manière, comme on dit en français « Ah, c'est quoi ?
C'est quoi ?"
Et à
ce moment-là, je me suis dit « Non seulement, il a supprimé la moitié des
mots, mais en
plus, il les met dans le mauvais ordre ».
Et c'est là le gros gap, c'est que je pense
qu'entre la théorie et la pratique, il y a une grosse différence.
Bien évidemment, il est important d'apprendre à faire une question d'une
manière correcte.
Il faut apprendre à dire « Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
» avant de dire « C'est quoi ?
parce qu'il faut connaître la base avant d'apprendre les différentes
nuances.
Mais si vous pensez qu'en connaissant la base théorique, ça va être
suffisant, ce
n'est pas le cas.
Et ça, en fait, je pense que c'est une sorte d'intuition où il faut après
apprendre
les différentes nuances du français parce que quand on parle dans la vie de
tous les
jours, je ne vais pas utiliser « Ah, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
» Je ne vais pas dire à ma femme
« Ah, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
» Je vais lui dire « Ah, c'est quoi ?
C'est quoi ?»
Et en fait, si vous ne faites pas d'immersion, si vous ne faites pas ce
genre de choses,
vous n'allez pas apprendre ce genre de nuance, une nuance dans la vie de
tous les jours.
Mais par contre, par exemple, si je parle avec la grand-mère de ma femme,
je vais peut-être
utiliser « Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
» Je vais utiliser une forme un peu plus polie, tout
simplement parce que je m'adapte un peu au contexte et du coup, il y a
plusieurs nuances.
Un autre exemple dans mon apprentissage du japonais, c'est que récemment,
j'essayais
avec ma femme, on a regardé le film « Demonslayer » et j'essayais un peu
de comprendre
en japonais.
En fait, je me suis rendu compte que ce qui était super dur, c'est que dans
la même
scène, il y avait un personnage qui parlait d'une manière super polie et un
autre qui
parlait d'une manière super slang.
Et en fait, des fois, il pouvait dire la même chose, mais d'une façon
totalement
différente.
Et en fait, même si je peux comprendre la forme neutre, si je ne connais
pas les nuances
très polies ou les nuances slang, en fait, je ne vais rien comprendre à la
scène, alors
que théoriquement, je suis censé pouvoir comprendre.
Si je vous donne un exemple en français, je vais dire par exemple une
phrase que vous
allez pouvoir trouver dans un textbook ou que vous allez pouvoir trouver
dans une discussion
assez polie.
C'est « Ah, mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait ?
Il va être en retard.
Ah, what is he doing ?
He's going to be late.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait ?
Il va être en retard.
Et en fait, si vous regardez un contenu natif, il y a beaucoup de chance
pour que
cette phrase devienne « Ah, mais putain, qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
Il va être à la bourre.
Ah, mais putain, mais qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
Il va être à la bourre là.
Et techniquement, le sens, vous devriez comprendre, mais juste le fait
que ce soit
dit de manière très déjà rapide, et en plus que j'utilise un peu une
nuance
très slang, enfin, ce n'est pas slang, mais c'est très casual, dans le
sens où
ça, c'est quelque chose que je pourrais dire par exemple devant mes
parents.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose de très vulgaire.
Et en fait, si vous n'avez pas cette nuance, tout de suite, le contenu
natif, il va devenir
très difficile à comprendre.
Et je pense que c'est là la difficulté, c'est là l'étape suivante, c'est de
découvrir les différentes nuances d'une langue, parce que la réalité, c'est
qu'on
parle très rarement dans un style neutre, on utilise rarement ce genre de
style neutre.
Je me rends compte quand je fais des live sur Twitch, des live jeux vidéo
où je parle
français lentement.
L'exemple, je pense, le plus facile, c'est avec les questions.
Quand on apprend le français, il y a trois types de questions, il y a
"Rising intonation",
donc par exemple, "Tu manges quoi ?
Tu manges quoi ?" On prend une phrase normale et on
mince comment dire.
La prononciation monte à la fin, et ça, c'est une question.
Ensuite, il y a "Est-ce que" "Qu'est-ce que tu manges ?" Et à la fin, il y a la
troisième version,
c'est l'inversion du sujet et du verbe.
"Que manges-tu ?" Bon, "Que manges-tu ?" je pense que je ne le dis jamais
dans la vie de tous
les jours.
Bien évidemment, c'est important de le connaître pour pouvoir le
reconnaître, pour pouvoir
le lire, l'écouter, mais après, c'est quelque chose qu'on utilise très peu.
En fait, je me rends compte que quand je joue à des jeux vidéo, j'alterne
un peu
entre les deux premiers.
Par exemple, je vais dire "Tu fais quoi ?
Tu fais quoi ?
Tu fais quoi ?" Et par contre,
après, je vais dire "Je suis en train de réfléchir en même temps, mais par
exemple,
je vais utiliser "Tu fais quoi ?" pour "What are you doing ?" et après, je
vais dire "Mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ?" Et je ne sais pas pourquoi, mais en fait, je jongle
un peu
entre les deux styles de questions.
Je passe un peu d'une question à l'autre et ça, c'est quelque chose, c'est
plus
de l'ordre de l'intuition, c'est plus de l'ordre de l'apprentissage
naturel, c'est
à force d'écouter du français natif, à force d'écouter, c'est pareil en
japonais
par exemple.
On développe ce genre d'intuition, on développe un peu une intuition
naturelle où on va
se dire "Bah, ça sonne mieux comme ça" en fait, je l'ai tellement entendu
de cette
manière que maintenant, je le dis comme ça et c'est ça, je pense l'étape
suivante.
Donc, quand vous êtes bloqué à ce genre d'étapes, il faut commencer, je
pense, à
essayer de s'orienter vers du contenu natif.
Donc, quand vous regardez tout le temps des podcasts comme celui-ci,
parfois, ça peut
être un peu ennuyant et vous pouvez avoir l'impression de bien comprendre
mais de ne
pas progresser.
Le plus difficile, c'est de passer au contenu natif.
C'est difficile parce qu'en fait, ce n'est plus un contenu qui est fait
pour vous, ce
n'est plus un contenu qui est adapté à votre niveau et du coup, là, ce
qu'il faut
de faire, c'est trouver une personne qui ne parle pas trop vite et si
possible qui
parle d'un sujet assez répétitif.
Personnellement, pour le japonais, j'ai regardé des téléréalités, donc là,
c'est vraiment
de la discussion de tous les jours et sinon, je regarde des let's play de
jeux vidéo.
Là, je regarde un let's play sur Zelda Breath of the Wild et je regarde un
autre
jeu vidéo que je vais peut-être faire en stream qui s'appelle La vie à la
campagne
au Japon.
Mais en fait, comme les personnes dans le jeu, elles font plusieurs actions
assez répétitives,
ça permet aussi de créer de la répétition et d'apprendre plus facilement.
Et en fait, là, le truc, c'est que comme c'est des streams de jeux vidéo,
ça va
être un style assez casual, mais du coup, je me rends compte que je
commence à m'habituer
un peu à ce style.
Après, la question que je me pose, c'est comment est-ce que je vais faire
pour apprendre
du japonais poli et ça, c'est pareil en français, c'est comment trouver un
contenu
qui est très poli pour s'habituer à ce genre de nuances de la langue.
Ça, je pense que ça va être par exemple avec des séries, si vous prenez par
exemple
une série très à la mode en ce moment les Chroniques de Bridgerton, je
pense que si
vous regardez les Chroniques de Bridgerton en français, ça va être un
langage assez
soutenu.
Ils vont parler très poliment parce que c'est la cour, il y a la reine,
etc.
Et je pense qu'après, c'est pareil par exemple pour des contenus orientés
un peu pour le
travail, c'est essayer d'orienter un peu les contenus qu'on regarde.
Du coup, si vous avez le sentiment que vous ne progressez plus, ça vaut le
coup de vous
demander est-ce que je ne peux pas essayer de regarder un style de contenu
qui va plus
sur une autre nuance de la langue.
On a une nuance neutre et après, il faut essayer d'aller autour, voir un
peu comment
sont construites les phrases, quel est le
vocabulaire utilisé,
etc.
Et ça, c'est une étape qui n'est pas facile, qui n'est pas évidente.
Si c'est trop difficile, peut-être que ça veut dire que vous devez encore
pratiquer
un niveau de langue neutre, mais après quand vous commencez à arriver à
basculer sur
d'autres nuances, je pense que ça devient très intéressant.
Et du coup, c'est pour ça que je pense que ce genre de podcast, c'est assez
complémentaire
avec les live que je fais sur des jeux vidéo.
Ce podcast, en plus, je n'ai pas de script, donc ça garde quand même un
style un peu
naturel, mais je fais attention à utiliser des formes correctes, on va dire
d'un point
de vue théorique, mais après, forcément, quand je joue à un jeu vidéo, ça
va être
plus naturel.
Vous allez avoir d'autres podcasts sur YouTube avec des scripts qui vont
être très théoriques,
on va dire, qui vont utiliser un français basique, très théorique, correct,
et après,
il faut réussir à commencer à aller vers de plus en plus d'autres nuances
de la langue.
Voilà, j'espère que c'était clair.
C'est quelque chose dont j'ai fait l'expérience, enfin, que je suis en
train de faire l'expérience
pour mon apprentissage du japonais, et je pense que c'est une des
difficultés qu'on
peut avoir.
Au début, on a un peu cette image de se dire « ah mais en fait, si
j'apprends toutes
les règles de grammaire, je vais pouvoir comprendre, je vais pouvoir
parler, mais en
fait, ce n'est pas vraiment le cas ».
Il y a vraiment cette dimension de l'apprentissage
naturel avec l'intuition qui prend du temps, et ça demande juste de faire
beaucoup d'immersion.
Bien évidemment, vous pouvez l'apprendre d'une manière plus théorique, mais
je pense
que c'est plus efficace et c'est plus amusant surtout de le faire via une
immersion.
Quand vous commencez à pouvoir regarder, écouter du contenu natif et que ça
vous plaît,
je pense que c'est là où vous progressez vraiment parce que je me rends
compte qu'un
moment avec le japonais, pour les podcasts, ça devenait un peu ennuyant
parce que c'était
assez répétitif pour les podcasts, et je fais la même chose.
Et je sens que là, en prenant plaisir à regarder des Let's Play sur des
jeux vidéo,
je sens que j'ai vraiment envie de regarder du contenu, de continuer à
regarder.
Et donc ça, c'est la clé.
Enfin voilà, j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à laisser un like et un commentaire.
Là, on est jeudi, jeudi 12 mars, demain on va aller installer le stand à la
convention
à Paris.
Ce week-end, je pense faire un petit vlog, mais je pense seulement le
poster sur Patreon
parce que ça va être assez répétitif aussi avec le vlog de lundi.
Et d'ailleurs, le vlog de la convention n'a pas très bien marché, donc,
mais merci
en tout cas pour tous les commentaires.
C'est bizarre parce qu'il ne me fait pas beaucoup de vues, mais j'ai
beaucoup de
retours de personnes.
Je ne sais pas, mais en tout cas, merci d'avoir commenté la vidéo.
Merci pour le soutien et je vous dis à la semaine prochaine pour une autre
vidéo.